Comme je disais aujourd'hui, ça fait un moment, je pense que c'est une bonne pratique et je n'ai pas toujours l'habitude de l'apprendre,
que notre frère Nathanaël ou même Loïc font souvent d'encourager les frères à pouvoir lire la portion du chapitre.
Et je pense que je prendrai l'habitude, parce que ça aurait été bien qu'on puisse relire l'Ézéchiel, le chapitre 5 en entier, avant de pouvoir revenir.
C'est vrai qu'on l'a abordé plusieurs fois, mais pour le résumer rapidement, c'est Dieu qui a exilé à cause de leur péché, qui a exilé le peuple d'Israël,
donc du royaume du Juda, ils ont été exilés à Babylone et quand ils sont exilés à Babylone, ils ont du mal à reconnaître que c'est Dieu qui a fait cela.
Pour eux, ce n'est pas Dieu, ce sont des circonstances hasardeuses qui les ont conduites à Babylone.
Mais Dieu rappelle, et voilà pourquoi il va lever plusieurs prophètes, notamment Ézéchiel, pour rappeler que c'est lui qui les a amenés à Babylone.
Et plusieurs fois, il va exhorter le peuple d'Israël à partir au travers d'Ézéchiel.
Et il y a cette partie où, dans le chapitre 5, il demande à Ézéchiel de prendre un instrument tranchant, de se raser la barbe et les cheveux.
Et au travers de ce rasage, de pouvoir exprimer le jugement qui va tomber sur Jérusalem.
Donc au travers des portions de cheveux qu'il allait disperser au vent, il allait symboliser.
Il y a des cheveux qui allaient être brûlés au feu, d'autres dispersés au vent.
Mais tout cela allait symboliser ce qui allait arriver sur Jérusalem.
Donc plus tard, je vous invite aussi à pouvoir relire le chapitre 5.
Aujourd'hui, nous allons nous concentrer sur les versets 15 au verset 17.
Et comme je vous ai dit, nous arrivons à la conclusion de ce chapitre 5.
Et je pense que là, quand notre frère a lu tout à l'heure, c'était des parties assez difficiles.
Quand on voit le verset 16, quand je lancerai sur eux les flèches pernicieuses de la famine qui donne la mort.
Et que j'enverrai pour vous détruire, car j'ajouterai la famine à vos maux et je briserai pour vous le bâton du pain.
J'enverrai contre vous la famine et les bêtes féroces qui te priveront d'enfants.
La peste et le sang passeront au milieu de toi.
Je ferai venir l'épée sur toi, c'est moi l'éternel qui parle.
Donc Dieu annonce des jugements qui viendront avec force sur la nation.
Notamment sur Jérusalem, sa capitale, qui va symboliser la destruction de tout le pays.
Cette destruction était donc symbolisée par ce signe.
Donc il est en train d'annoncer.
Donc Jérusalem n'est pas encore détruite.
C'est très important pour nous de garder cela à l'esprit.
C'est-à-dire Dieu annonce par Ézéchiel que Jérusalem va être détruite dans quelques temps.
Ce n'est pas encore le cas.
Et Dieu signale que ce jugement arrive parce qu'Israël, qui était le peuple censé être la lumière des nations,
par sa consécration à Dieu, par son obéissance à la loi,
a au contraire méprisé la parole de Dieu.
Ce n'est même pas qu'ils ignoraient ce qu'ils étaient en train de faire.
Ils étaient conscients de ce qu'ils étaient en train de faire.
Ils ont méprisé la parole de Dieu.
Ils ont souillé le sanctuaire du temple.
Là où il y avait la présence de Dieu au milieu de son peuple.
Et à cause de cela, Dieu promet d'assouvir sa colère.
Donc ce sont les mots qui sont là.
C'est répété au moins six fois, rien que sur le chapitre 5.
Dieu promet d'assouvir sa colère, de faire reposer sa fureur à cause de ses péchés.
Et cela s'accompagnera de signes qui prouveront que c'est bien Dieu qui en est l'auteur.
Et c'est ce qu'il prouve au travers de la dernière phrase du chapitre.
C'est moi l'éternel qui parle.
Quelle est la vérité qui va ressortir là-dessus qui est aussi importante pour nous ?
C'est que le but de Dieu, lorsqu'il parle ainsi à Ézéchiel,
était de faire comprendre à Israël la gravité de l'idolâtrie.
C'est-à-dire Israël n'avait pas encore conscience du péché dans lequel ils avaient été plongés.
Dieu voulait leur faire prendre conscience de la gravité de l'idolâtrie,
de la gravité de l'apostasie.
Donc l'apostasie c'était le fait de renier.
C'est-à-dire Dieu c'était à qui ce peuple ?
C'était un peuple qui était en esclavage.
Dieu les sauve de l'esclavage et Dieu dit je serai votre Dieu.
Et eux ils décident, quand on parle d'apostasie, c'est qu'ils décident de renier Dieu.
Ils décident de renier tout ce que Dieu porte aussi,
tous les commandements qui accompagnent le Seigneur.
Donc ils ont renié Dieu en se cherchant d'autres dieux.
Ils ont renoncé au rôle que Dieu leur avait donné auprès des autres nations,
d'être la nation qui était une lumière, mais surtout d'être la nation qui devait servir d'accueil du Messie.
Et le Messie devait toucher le reste des nations.
L'origine de la création d'Israël trouve sa source dans Genèse.
Dès le moment où Adam et Ève ont péché,
Dieu promet à Adam et Ève que même s'ils ont échoué,
il promet qu'un jour il va restaurer toutes ces choses.
Il fera quelque chose.
Et quand il promet cette restauration,
donc il va acquérir un peuple,
un peuple qui n'a aucun mérite,
il va décider d'en faire son peuple pour préparer la venue du Messie.
Et ce n'était pas pour que la venue du Messie s'arrête à Israël,
c'était que pour que toutes les nations puissent recevoir cette lumière de Dieu.
Et donc Israël devait comprendre que les jugements qui accompagnaient ces péchés,
après des siècles de patience et de pardon,
étaient réels.
Donc voilà, il reprend l'expression, c'est moi l'éternel qui parle.
Ça agit comme une signature que Dieu confirme en scellant le destin du peuple.
Donc ce matin, nous allons voir qu'est-ce que Dieu voulait leur enseigner
lorsqu'il dit qu'il faisait des sujets d'opprobre et de honte.
Qu'est-ce que nous, nous pouvons apprendre de cela,
pourquoi Dieu souligne, parce que vous voyez,
si vous avez fait attention pendant que nous lisions le texte,
il répète au moins trois fois, à partir du verset 13 au verset 17,
il y a au moins trois fois, c'est moi l'éternel qui parle.
Dieu est en train d'apporter une sorte de signature.
Et nous allons voir aussi pourquoi Dieu apporte cette sorte de signature personnelle
quand il est en train d'annoncer ses jugements.
Alors, le premier point, qu'est-ce que Dieu voulait leur enseigner
en faisant d'eux un sujet d'opprobre et de honte ?
Je relis le verset 15.
Dieu, Jérusalem n'est pas encore détruite,
mais Dieu annonce qu'à un moment, l'humiliation, la honte
vont caractériser désormais Israël.
Après des siècles de patience,
pour essayer de vous restituer les choses,
lorsque Dieu donne les dix commandements
et donne même les livres du Pentateuch,
nous sommes à peu près à 1200 avant Jésus-Christ.
Lorsque le Seigneur est en train de parler au travers d'Ézéchiel,
nous sommes à peu près entre 1700-1800 avant Jésus-Christ.
Et après, lorsque Dieu va restaurer le peuple d'Israël,
il va les ramener sur leur territoire,
sur la terre de Canaan.
À partir des derniers prophètes,
il y a quatre siècles de silence
jusqu'à ce que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ arrive.
Donc, sur cette période,
nous sommes à peu près à huit siècles après Moïse,
après que Moïse ait donné la loi.
Donc, après des siècles de patience,
Dieu décidait de juger durement
l'idolâtrie du peuple d'Israël.
Il ne les avait jamais.
Ce qu'il était en train de faire,
c'est vrai qu'il avait fait avec le royaume du Nord,
qui avait déjà été à la base idolâtre,
mais Dieu avait conservé sa patience
envers le peuple, le royaume de Juda.
Et là maintenant,
après plusieurs siècles de patience,
Dieu décidait de juger leur péché d'idolâtrie.
C'est important de parler de ce péché d'idolâtrie
parce que c'est le péché qui avait ouvert la porte
à de nombreux autres péchés.
C'est très important pour nous de retenir ce lien.
Et voilà pourquoi Dieu,
quand il donne le premier commandement,
quand nous lisons Exode 20,
qu'est-ce qu'il dit?
Alors Dieu prononcera toutes ces paroles en disant,
« Je suis l'éternel ton Dieu
qui t'ai fait sortir du pays d'Égypte
de la maison de servitude.
Tu n'auras pas d'autre Dieu devant ma face. »
Il n'a pas d'abord parlé d'honorer le prochain.
Il n'a pas d'abord parlé de quelque chose.
Le premier commandement,
« Tu n'auras pas d'autre Dieu devant ma face. »
C'était le premier commandement que Dieu donne.
Ce peuple, donc le peuple d'Israël,
qui avait maintes et maintes fois vu le secours de Dieu,
allait maintenant être confronté à des ennemis
qui allaient triompher de lui,
d'une façon qu'il n'avait jamais vu jusqu'à présent,
par la grâce de Dieu.
Il est arrivé que des peuples les soumettent,
les obligent à payer un tribut,
mais jamais un peuple ne les avait arrachés.
Même d'ailleurs, depuis que David avait fait de Jérusalem
la capitale du royaume,
jamais Jérusalem n'avait été prise par une nation étrangère.
Donc ce qui était en train de se passer
était quelque chose qu'ils avaient du mal à imaginer
parce qu'ils savaient que la grâce de Dieu reposait sur eux.
Mais pourtant, Dieu leur annonce un tel niveau de destruction.
Il leur souligne
qu'Israël va être un objet des fois.
Et voilà ce qu'il dit à un moment.
Jérémie, parce qu'il y a beaucoup de concordances aussi,
au même moment, Jérémie aussi est vivant.
Et Jérémie est en train de prêcher la même chose qu'Ézéchiel.
Voilà ce que dit Jérémie.
Je ne sais pas si ça a l'air un peu trop fort.
Peut-être un peu reculé.
Jérémie, 22, verset 8 à 9.
Voilà cette expression.
Nous pouvons comprendre cette expression
lorsqu'il dit à un moment, vous serez un objet des fois.
Des nations nombreuses passeront près de cette ville.
Donc il parle de Jérusalem.
Et elles se diront l'une à l'autre,
pourquoi l'Éternel a-t-il ainsi traité cette grande ville ?
Et l'on répondra,
parce qu'ils ont abandonné l'alliance de l'Éternel leur Dieu,
parce qu'ils se sont prosternés devant d'autres dieux
et les ont servis.
Vous voyez, le péché qui est mis en avant,
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils ont oublié d'honorer leur prochain.
Le péché qui est mis en avant,
c'est parce qu'ils ont commis le péché d'idolâtrie.
Même les nations alentours.
Donc là, ce sont les nations.
Le texte que Jérémie prend,
c'est de dire au moment que même les nations autour
vont comprendre que ces jugements venaient de Dieu.
Israël était peut-être dans le déni,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils avaient du mal à reconnaître
que cela était en train de venir de Dieu,
mais ils finiraient aussi par le réaliser.
Dieu n'était pas injuste.
Ce sont eux qui n'avaient pas respecté l'alliance
qui avait été établie avec lui
lors de l'entrée dans la terre de Canaan.
Et si vous vous souvenez,
nous étions revenus sur ce point.
Voilà pourquoi, lorsque nous avions abordé
ce chapitre 5,
la première chose que nous avions abordé,
c'était de comprendre la colère de Dieu.
C'était de comprendre que la colère de Dieu
n'est pas comme notre colère
où à un moment, nous nous emportons sans raison,
sans compréhension,
avec un manque de tact,
un manque de sagesse.
Mais la colère de Dieu
est une colère sainte,
est une colère juste.
C'est toujours important
que nous puissions garder cela à l'esprit.
Même lorsque nous sommes en train de lire
un passage comme le verset 16,
qui nous parle de choses difficiles,
des versets 16 à 17,
qui vont même nous parler de cannibalisme,
qui vont nous parler de beaucoup de choses difficiles,
Dieu n'est pas injuste.
Qu'est-ce que nous pouvons apprendre de cela ?
Ça, c'est le deuxième point.
Tout d'abord,
et c'est pour ça que je vous ai fait ce rappel,
nous voyons que tous ces avertissements
et les jugements qui suivent
avaient été annoncés des siècles avant.
Je vous ai dit à un moment,
Moïse, on se situe à peu près,
c'est 1200 ans avant Jésus-Christ.
Moïse, Dieu donne les dix commandements à Moïse,
Dieu donne le Pentateuch à Moïse,
donc il comprend les livres d'Exode,
Nombre, Lévitique, Deutéronome.
Il donne ces commandements,
12 siècles, on va dire,
8 siècles avant dans leur cas.
Et donc ces commandements ont été,
étaient déjà connus d'Israël
pendant plusieurs siècles.
Ces commandements rythmaient la vie d'Israël,
ils ne l'ignoraient pas.
mais Israël avait échoué à honorer
ces commandements.
Et le plus important de ces commandements,
c'était lequel?
Deutéronome 6, versets 4 à 5.
Écoute Israël,
l'éternel notre Dieu est le seul éternel.
Tu aimeras l'éternel ton Dieu
de tout ton cœur,
de toute ton âme et de toute ta force.
Là encore, c'était le commandement
le plus important.
Et d'ailleurs, le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
va mettre cette en face
et ce commandement
qu'il va rappeler
comme étant le plus important.
Si nous comprenons ce commandement,
si nous vivons ce commandement,
tous les autres commandements
vont être vécus.
Mais il va dire un moment,
il va citer ce commandement,
mais il va aussi citer
le fait d'aimer le prochain.
Mais nous verrons le lien
qu'il y a.
Et donc,
Dieu donne ce commandement,
ces commandements à Moïse.
Moïse les transmet
à des hommes fidèles
comme Josué
et plusieurs autres,
David et autres.
Et donc,
sous l'impulsion
de plusieurs chefs,
de plusieurs rois,
des juges,
qui étaient soumis à Dieu,
la nation d'Israël
a été amenée
à craindre l'éternel.
Donc,
à cause
de tels hommes,
ces commandements,
ils ont entraîné
la nation
à craindre l'éternel.
Mais ce que nous réalisons
lorsque nous sommes en train
d'arriver
à ce jugement,
c'est que le cœur
d'Israël
n'a jamais été
dans la disposition
d'aimer l'éternel
avec l'engagement
de tout leur être.
C'était un engagement,
c'était un amour forcé.
Plusieurs fois
dans les Écritures,
pourquoi nous parlons
d'un amour forcé ?
C'est que si vous lisez
l'Ancien Testament,
vous allez voir plusieurs fois,
c'est-à-dire même
après la mort,
déjà même du vivant
de Moïse,
Dieu délivre
le peuple d'Israël
de l'esclavage
de l'Égypte
où ils étaient
réduits en esclavage
depuis plusieurs siècles.
Et lorsque Dieu
leur dit à un moment,
je suis l'éternel
votre Dieu
et qu'il leur commande
même de ne pas
se faire d'idole et autre,
la première chose
qu'ils vont faire
quand ils sont dans
les déserts,
c'est de se créer
une idole.
Aaron dit qu'à un moment
qu'il a été obligé,
c'est toujours une des histoires
drôles,
quand il dit à un moment,
j'ai été obligé
de faire le vaudor.
Ils ont fabriqué
un vaudor,
ils ont adoré un vaudor.
Un peu une représentation
de ce qu'ils avaient
laissé en Égypte.
Et donc nous voyons
déjà que dès le début,
leur cœur n'a jamais
été dans la disposition
d'aimer l'éternel
avec tout cet engagement.
Ils voulaient aimer
l'éternel
avec un cœur partagé.
Et plusieurs fois
dans les Écritures,
nous allons voir
qu'ils se détournaient
de Dieu
et quand ils subissaient
les souffrances
dues à l'ordre
des obéissances,
ils revenaient à Dieu.
Et un des exemples
les plus frappants,
vous pourrez le lire
dans le livre de Samuel,
c'est lorsque
les fils d'Élie,
qui avaient été
le menteur de Samuel,
vont à la bataille.
Ils étaient partis
sans l'arche de l'Alliance
et à un moment,
ils sont en train de voir
qu'ils perdent la bataille.
Ils réalisent un moment
et il faut qu'on apporte
l'arche de l'Alliance
parce qu'on va sûrement
gagner la bataille.
On est en train de perdre
parce que Dieu
n'est pas avec nous.
Ils avaient choisi délibérément
de ne pas aller
avec l'arche de l'Alliance
parce qu'ils savaient
ce qu'ils portaient
dans leur cœur.
Et quand ils voient
qu'ils perdent la bataille,
ils décident de ramener
l'arche de l'Alliance.
Mais Dieu ne va pas
les honorer.
Dieu préfère
même encore
que l'arche
soit prise par les Philistins
et il va se glorifier
même au milieu des Philistins
pour les obliger
à renvoyer l'arche.
Mais cet épisode
nous montre un moment
ce que j'étais en train de dire.
On va retrouver cet épisode,
ce cycle plusieurs fois.
Il y a un juge
qui oblige le peuple,
qui conduit le peuple
à honorer l'éternel.
Quand ce juge meurt,
le peuple se détourne de Dieu
en repartant vers
de fausses idoles.
Une nation voisine
les soumet en esclavage.
Il crie à l'éternel,
Dieu suscite un juge,
le juge les délivre
et on reprend le même cycle.
Donc, nous voyons
que l'amour d'Israël
envers Dieu,
c'était un amour
qui était rempli
par la crainte du châtiment.
Ce n'était pas un amour
vrai,
c'était une crainte
qui ne trouvait pas
sa source dans l'amour
envers Dieu
comme serait l'amour
d'un petit enfant,
par exemple.
Parce que souvent,
on peut se demander,
quand nous voulons comprendre
la crainte
que nous devons avoir
vis-à-vis de Dieu,
c'est la crainte
qu'un enfant
aurait
envers ses parents
une crainte mêlée
de respect,
d'amour.
Mais la crainte
qu'Israël avait,
et c'était paradoxal,
ils avaient une crainte
comme si c'était
un Dieu tyran,
c'était comme si c'était
un Dieu qui les obligeait
à quelque chose
dont ils n'avaient pas envie.
Ce Dieu qui les avait
libérés de l'esclavage
de l'Égypte,
ce Dieu qui les avait
conduits dans une terre
d'abondance,
ils avaient du mal,
ils le trouvaient
trop exigeant.
Et donc,
c'était un amour
qui était guidé
par des intérêts.
C'était un amour
où ils essayaient
de voir ce qu'ils
pouvaient tirer de Dieu,
comme on a pris
l'exemple dans 1 Samuel.
Ils voyaient
ce qu'ils pouvaient
tirer de Dieu
quand ils étaient
dans la détresse
ou même
dans la prospérité.
Plusieurs fois,
ils ont utilisé
le nom de Dieu
pour aller à l'encontre
de sa parole.
nous lisons,
lorsque vous allez lire
les petits prophètes,
une emphase
de beaucoup
de petits prophètes,
c'est de pointer
l'injustice
qu'il y avait
en Israël,
de voir comment
ceux qui étaient
dans la prospérité
oubliaient le pauvre,
oubliaient la veuve
et l'orphelin.
Et ça,
c'était un péché
vis-à-vis de Dieu.
Et encore aujourd'hui,
beaucoup de personnes,
c'est comme ça
que beaucoup de personnes
voient,
et on peut même
parler de religion,
la religion,
c'est essayer
de calmer un Dieu
qui est en colère
contre nous.
Beaucoup de personnes
vont s'approcher
de Dieu,
vont se faire
une idée de Dieu,
ils vont l'honorer
par leur bouche
et leurs lèvres,
mais avec un cœur
éloigné,
parce que le désir
n'est pas d'aimer Dieu.
Le désir,
c'est une crainte
de Dieu
qui vient de tradition
humaine,
c'est une crainte
de Dieu
qui vient à cause
de superstition.
C'est une crainte
de Dieu,
on va aller à l'église
parce que
on a un entretien
mercredi,
donc si le pasteur
ne t'avait pas vu
depuis des jours,
il va peut-être
apercevoir
ta tête mercredi
parce que
là,
il faut que tu ailles
prier pour que
Dieu te bénisse
avec cet entretien.
Beaucoup de personnes
abordent Dieu
avec
l'intérêt
et la crainte
du châtiment.
Dans la continuité
de ce que ça nous enseigne,
Paul nous rappelle
dans 1 Corinthien
au chapitre 10,
donc je vous inviterai
encore là
à lire plus tard
dans 1 Corinthien 10,
il va parler de,
il est en train
de récapituler
pourquoi
la rébellion,
l'idolâtrie
des enfants d'Israël
doit nous servir
d'exemple
et doit nous mettre
en garde.
Et donc,
Paul nous dit
à un moment
que ce que nous sommes
en train de voir,
même ce que nous sommes
en train de lire
dans ce texte
que nous avons lu
du verset 13
au verset 17,
ça doit nous servir
d'exemple
sur les conséquences
du péché d'idolâtrie.
C'est ce péché
que Dieu pointe,
ce péché d'idolâtrie,
c'est le fait
de détourner
notre affection de Dieu
pour la tourner
vers des idoles,
qu'elles soient physiques
ou non.
Et ce péché d'idolâtrie,
c'est le péché
qui ouvre la porte
à une multitude
de péchés dans nos vies.
Le fait
de placer,
et lorsque nous parlons
du péché d'idolâtrie,
enfin,
souvent un peu
dans notre culture chrétienne,
on a un peu tendance
quand même
à pouvoir décrire
ce que va être une idole.
On va dire,
généralement,
qu'une idole,
c'est la chose
qui prend le plus de place
dans notre vie
à la place de Dieu.
Si à un moment,
par rapport à la parole,
je ne peux pas être là dimanche
parce que mon travail
est plus important que Dieu,
ça, c'est déjà
une idole à un moment.
Si à un moment,
je ne peux pas
aider les frères et les sœurs
parce que je ne veux pas
sortir de ma zone de confort
et que je trouve
que je suis bien
là où je suis
et qu'aider les personnes,
ça demande trop d'efforts,
trop d'engagement,
là, je suis déjà
en train de me constituer
une idole.
Les idoles,
elles sont multiples.
Nous lisons la parole de Dieu,
nous pouvons trouver
beaucoup de choses
qui vont s'opposer
à la Seigneurie de Dieu
dans notre vie.
Mais nous voyons
que Paul est en train de,
et même dans 1 Corinthien,
10,
il va même souligner en disant
de fuir,
de fuir le péché d'idolâtrie.
Pourquoi Paul insiste
sur ce péché d'idolâtrie ?
Le principe du péché d'idolâtrie,
c'est d'écarter Dieu
dans notre vie.
Le principe du péché d'idolâtrie,
c'est que lorsque nous lisons
Deutéronome 6 au verset 5,
c'est que nous décidons
de ne pas obéir à cela.
Lorsque les hommes,
parce qu'aujourd'hui,
la réalité qu'il y a,
c'est que chacun de nous,
que tu sois croyant ou pas,
chacun de nous,
nous avons des évidences
de l'existence de Dieu.
Quand nous regardons la nature,
nous voyons des preuves,
des évidences de l'existence de Dieu.
Pour nous croyants,
nous voyons ce que Dieu a fait
dans notre vie
et nous voyons des preuves
de l'existence de Dieu.
Lorsque nous voyons encore
de la bonté humaine,
que nous pouvons voir des tribunaux,
nous pouvons encore voir
une certaine justice
par rapport au péché,
nous voyons des preuves
de l'existence de Dieu.
Mais le péché d'idolâtrie,
c'est le principe à un moment
de ne pas engager tout notre être
à aimer Dieu.
Et quels sont les fruits
que nous portons
lorsque nous décidons
d'écarter Dieu.
Et voilà pourquoi
le péché d'idolâtrie
est un péché très grave
qui ouvre la porte
à de nombreux autres péchés.
Lorsque nous décidons
d'écarter Dieu de notre vie
et de pouvoir nous mettre
des idoles à notre place,
non seulement nous décidons
de souffrir nous-mêmes,
mais nous décidons aussi
de faire souffrir
ce que Dieu place
sur notre chemin.
Regardons ce que causent
dans notre vie
les mauvaises pensées
envers notre prochain.
Regardons les soupçons
que nous pouvons avoir
vis-à-vis de certaines personnes,
des soupçons
qui ne sont pas fondés.
Regardons la haine
que les gens peuvent avoir.
Regardons les rancunes
Quand vous rencontrez
des gens qui vont te dire
« Ça fait 20 ans
que je n'ai plus fêté
Noël avec ma famille
parce qu'il avait eu
une dispute
et il a une rancune. »
Donc pendant 20 ans,
il va entretenir
cette rancune.
Même ses enfants
n'ont pas le droit
de voir le reste
de sa famille
parce qu'il a gardé
une rancune.
Ça, c'est la preuve
à un moment
qu'on a refusé
d'aimer Dieu
de tout notre être
et qu'on l'a remplacé
avec des idoles.
Les meurtres d'individus,
les meurtres par des individus
ou des États
à cause de la cupidité,
de la jalousie,
de l'orgueil.
La Bible nous dit
à un moment
que le crime
paraît être un jeu
pour l'insensé.
Regardons avec quelle facilité
certains se permettent
de balancer des bombes
sur des populations civiles
et de trouver cela normal
pour des personnes
qui pourraient être
leur père,
leur mère,
leur frère,
leur soeur.
Regardons les adultères.
À un moment,
des personnes qui peuvent
avoir tout ce qu'ils ont
dans leur vie.
Ils ont une bonne famille,
ils ont toutes ces choses
en apparence,
mais ils vont décider
de détruire
leur famille
par l'adultère,
les impudicités
qui dérèglent
la vision de l'amour.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans une société
totalement déréglée
dans ce sens,
avec toutes les conséquences
que ça entraîne,
les avortements,
des naissances non désirées,
des maladies sexuelles,
toutes ces choses.
Les vols,
toutes les injustices
qui les accompagnent,
les faux témoignages
qui sont légions.
Là,
j'avais une amie avocate
qui était en train
de dire à un moment
que ce qui est dommage
souvent,
même dans la parole
de femmes
qui vont subir
des violences,
c'est qu'il y a tellement,
et elle est avocate,
donc elle parle d'une réalité,
elle va dire,
il y a tellement de femmes
qui produisent
de faux mensonges
qu'à un moment,
ça discrédite
celles qui sont
de vraies victimes.
Regardons les calomnies.
Toutes ces choses
proviennent de cœurs
qui se sont détournés
de Dieu.
Toutes ces choses
proviennent de cœurs
qui vont trouver normal
de vivre dans ce genre
de choses,
qui vont même trouver
moral,
parce qu'aujourd'hui,
on a placé l'adultère
comme étant une chose morale.
Il est tout à fait normal
de commettre l'adultère,
parce que si on en sent
l'envie,
on va commettre l'adultère.
On va trouver normal
de pratiquer ses péchés
malgré les conséquences
néfastes
qui les accompagnent.
Donc,
aussi bien par l'exemple
des Israélites,
et donc ce que je suis
en train de vous citer,
c'est ce qu'il y avait
au milieu du peuple
d'Israël,
avant que Dieu
ne les juge,
et ce que Dieu
leur reproche.
Et donc,
aussi bien par l'exemple
que ce que nous pouvons
voir dans notre société
aujourd'hui,
c'est aussi un rappel,
et c'est un rappel
qui est vrai,
c'est qu'un cœur
non régénéré
ne peut aimer
et servir Dieu.
La difficulté
qu'il y avait finalement
pour le peuple
d'Israël
à obéir
à Deutéronome,
chapitre 6,
verset 5,
par leur échec
à obéir
à ce commandement,
Dieu démontre
qu'ils étaient incapables
de pouvoir venir
à Dieu
par leurs propres efforts.
Si ce que nous voyons,
si Dieu n'opère
pas un changement
de cœur,
nous ne pouvons
que le servir
et nous allons penser
l'aimer
de façon erronée.
Aujourd'hui,
regardons,
il y a des personnes
qui vont marcher
pendant 3,
4 kilomètres,
ils vont se traîner
sur les genoux
en portant une croix,
en espérant trouver
la paix.
Cette façon erronée
de chercher Dieu,
de comprendre Dieu
dans plusieurs religions.
Mais ce que Dieu
enseigna à Israël,
c'est qu'il leur faisait
comprendre que non seulement
il existait,
mais qu'en plus,
il était fidèle
à sa parole.
Et donc,
lorsqu'il était en train
de parler
qu'ils allaient être
un sujet d'effroi,
ils allaient être
un sujet de honte,
c'était aussi pour enseigner
aux nations alentours
ce qui est en train
de se passer.
Ce qui se passe
n'a jamais été vu ailleurs.
Et si vous avez la preuve
que ça a été vu ailleurs,
nous pouvons discuter après.
Mais il n'y a
aucune nation,
dans aucune nation,
les nations ont eu
des dieux
depuis des siècles.
Il n'y a aucun dieu
de ces nations païennes
qui a pu prophétiser
des choses
12 siècles,
8 siècles avant
qui se sont réalisés
avec exactitude plus tard.
Il n'y a que dans la Bible
que vous allez voir
ces choses.
Il n'y a que dans la Bible
où vous allez voir
un moment que ce que
le Seigneur a annoncé
comme jugement
ou comme bénédiction
ou comme malédiction
sur Israël
se sont accomplis
littéralement
plusieurs siècles
plus tard.
Et donc,
pour les nations
qui allaient voir
le jugement
d'Israël,
en voyant un moment
que Dieu est en train
d'annoncer ce jugement
par ses prophètes,
même plusieurs siècles avant,
ces nations allaient comprendre,
allaient dire un moment,
oui,
Israël avait un Dieu.
Oui,
ces choses n'étaient pas
dites par hasard.
Mais,
comme je vous ai dit,
en révélant cette incapacité
à lui obéir,
Dieu leur confirmait,
non seulement
Dieu leur confirmait
qu'ils avaient échoué
dans le fait
d'obéir à l'Alliance,
mais Dieu leur confirmait
aussi le besoin
qu'ils avaient
de placer leur espoir
dans la promesse
du libérateur.
Le problème,
c'est qu'Israël
le comprenait mal.
Jusqu'à présent,
Israël était certain.
C'est-à-dire,
lorsque Dieu promet
à Adam et Ève
de restaurer toute chose,
il promet
le fils qui viendra
et qui va restaurer
ce qu'ils ont perdu,
Israël n'avaient pas
compris dans quel sens.
C'est-à-dire,
même dans cet esclavage
du péché,
ils n'avaient pas compris
la délivrance
dans laquelle
ils allaient être.
Ils étaient toujours
en train de comprendre
une délivrance physique
qui est en train
de tout fausser
dans leur compréhension.
Mais,
par,
alors,
à l'époque,
ce qu'il y a,
c'est qu'il y avait
les sacrifices.
C'est-à-dire que
Dieu avait mis en place,
mais d'ailleurs,
dans toutes les nations,
à l'époque,
toutes les nations,
il y avait cette conscience
de Dieu,
aussi de pouvoir
apaiser Dieu
par des sacrifices.
Donc,
les nations alentours
sacrifiaient.
Alors,
ce qui est dommage,
c'est que les nations
alentours sacrifiaient
non seulement des animaux,
mais il leur arrivait
aussi de sacrifier
des personnes
pour pouvoir obtenir
la paix de leur Dieu.
Mais Dieu leur avait
interdit cela
au niveau d'Israël.
Donc,
les sacrifices en Israël
se résumaient
à des sacrifices d'animaux,
mais le renouvellement
constant des sacrifices
devait servir à Israël
de leur rappeler
que ces sacrifices
n'otaient pas les péchés,
sinon,
une fois que le sacrifice
était fait,
il n'aurait pas eu besoin
de le refaire.
Les sacrifices
n'otaient pas le péché,
mais les sacrifices
étaient là
dans l'attente
du sacrifice parfait
à venir.
Et voici le lien
que l'auteur des brefs
va faire
avec ce que nous sommes
en train de souligner
lorsque Dieu
va faire comprendre
à Israël
que le besoin qu'il y a,
vous avez échoué
à obéir à l'alliance
parce que vous n'aviez
pas des cœurs
régénérés.
Vous ne pouviez pas
accepter cette parole
parce que vous avez besoin
de l'œuvre
du salut
qui viendra
au travers du Seigneur
à Jésus-Christ.
Et lorsqu'il va dire
un moment dans Ézéchiel,
il va dire,
après ces jours-là,
voilà ce qu'il dit,
voici l'alliance
que je vais faire avec eux.
Après ces jours-là,
dit le Seigneur,
je mettrai mes lois
dans leur cœur.
Donc ce n'était pas le cas.
Cette loi était extérieure
et voilà pourquoi
ils avaient du mal
à l'accepter.
Il dit,
je mettrai cette loi
dans leur cœur
et je les écrirai
dans leur esprit.
Et il ajoute,
et je ne me souviendrai
plus de leurs péchés
ni de leurs iniquités.
Et donc l'auteur
des brefs fait ce lien
pour dire un moment,
il prend ce passage
d'Ézéchiel
pour exprimer
pourquoi le jugement
arrive sur Israël.
Israël n'avait pas compris.
Si Israël avait compris
que dans l'attente de Dieu,
il devait se préserver
de l'idolâtrie
et il devait persévérer
dans le fait
d'adorer Dieu
et Dieu seul
et de persévérer
dans les sacrifices,
ils allaient savoir
un moment qu'il persévérer
dans les sacrifices
parce qu'il devait servir
de nation d'accueil
pour celui qui allait
les libérer
du pouvoir du péché.
Ça n'avait pas été compris.
Et l'auteur des brefs
va nous dire un moment,
et je vais relire
en faisant le lien
avec le texte
que je viens de lire,
c'est dans Hébreu 10,
11 à 17,
il dit,
« Tandis que tout sacrificateur
fait chaque jour
le service
et offre souvent
les mêmes sacrifices
qui ne peuvent jamais
ôter les péchés,
lui, après avoir offert
un seul sacrifice
pour les péchés,
s'est assis pour toujours
à la droite de Dieu,
attendant désormais
que ses ennemis
soient devenus
son marche-pied.
Car par une seule offrande,
il a amené à la perfection
pour toujours
ceux qui sont sanctifiés. »
C'est ce que le Saint-Esprit
nous atteste aussi,
car après avoir dit,
« Voici l'alliance
que je ferai avec eux. »
Après ces jours-là,
dit le Seigneur,
« Je mettrai mes lois
dans leur cœur
et je les écrirai
dans leur esprit. »
Il ajoute,
« Et je ne me souviendrai
plus de leurs péchés
ni de leurs iniquités. »
Cela nous enseigne
un moment
qu'Israël n'avait pas compris.
Et du fait
qu'ils n'avaient pas compris
un moment
que ce commandement
d'aimer l'éternel
de leur Dieu,
de toute leur âme,
de toute leur force,
ils ne pouvaient l'accomplir.
Ils n'ont pas compris cela.
Non seulement
ils ne l'ont pas accompli,
mais non seulement
ils n'ont pas cherché
à dépendre de la grâce de Dieu
parce qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas l'accomplir.
Ils ne pouvaient pas l'accomplir,
mais ils ont choisi
de se tourner vers des idoles.
Je pense qu'on se comprend.
Les Israélites ont manifesté
une incrédulité
qui a été teintée
de mépris.
Et là encore,
je vais lire.
Vous voyez,
là c'est deux rois.
Ce sont des passages.
Nous allons lire
des passages
de deux rois,
de Jérémie aussi.
Et c'est important
de voir que deux rois,
c'est quelques siècles
avant Ézéchiel.
Voilà déjà
comment Dieu avertissait
Israël
par ses prophètes.
Deux rois 17,
versets 13 à 18.
L'éternel
fit avertir Israël
et Judas
par tous ses prophètes,
par tous les voyants
et leur dit
revenez de vos mauvaises voies
et observez
mes commandements
et mes ordonnances
en suivant entièrement
la loi que j'ai prescrite
à vos pères
et que je vous ai envoyé
par mes serviteurs
les prophètes.
Dieu savait
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
honorer la loi.
Dieu savait
qu'ils étaient
dans la capacité
de pouvoir honorer
ce commandement.
Mais voilà pourquoi
Dieu avait pourvu
au travers des sacrifices
pour qu'ils puissent
avoir le pardon
en attendant
l'œuvre parfaite
de Christ.
Et voilà pourquoi
il va dire à un moment
observez mes commandements
et mes ordonnances
en suivant entièrement
la loi.
Donc il parle
de ce principe
des sacrifices.
Ils ont cherché
à suivre
ils ont cherché
à honorer
ces commandements
mais sans suivre
la loi.
Ils ont été
incapables
de respecter la loi
mais en voulant
suivre les commandements
et lorsqu'ils n'ont pas
pu le faire
ils se sont tournés
vers d'autres dieux
et c'est ça
que Dieu leur reproche.
Et d'ailleurs
on le voit
dans le point suivant
ils n'écoutèrent point
et ils roidirent
leurs cours
comme leur père
qui n'avait pas cru
en l'éternel
leur Dieu.
Ils rejetèrent
ces lois
l'alliance qu'ils avaient
faite avec leur père
et les avertissements
qu'il leur avait adressés.
Ils allèrent
après des choses
de néant
et ne furent
eux-mêmes
que néant
et après les nations
qui les entouraient
et que l'éternel
leur avait défendu
d'imiter.
Ils abandonnèrent
tous les commandements
de l'éternel
leur Dieu
et se firent
de deux veaux
en fente
et ils fabriquèrent
des idoles
d'astarté
et se prosternèrent
devant toute l'armée
des cieux
et ils servirent
Baal.
Ils firent passer
par le feu
leurs fils
et leurs filles
et se livrèrent
à la divination
et aux enchantements
et ils se vendirent
pour faire
ce qui est mal
aux yeux de l'éternel
afin de l'irriter.
Aussi,
l'éternel
s'est-il fortement
irrité contre Israël
et les a-t-il
éloignés de sa face ?
Il n'est resté
que la seule tribu
de Judas.
Le premier jugement,
nous voyons
un moment
que lorsque
Ézéchiel va être
en train
de manifester
les signes,
il va déjà
parler du royaume.
À la mort
de Salomon,
le royaume
va être divisé
en deux.
Il y aura
le royaume
du Judas
au sud
et le royaume
d'Israël
avec les dix
tribus
au nord.
Et ce royaume
va déjà être détruit
à cause
des mêmes péchés.
Donc,
les péchés
qui viennent
d'être cités,
ce sont les péchés
que le royaume
du nord
commettait,
mais aussi
le royaume
du sud.
Et Dieu
va les pointer
au travers
des prophètes.
Et parce qu'ils ont,
et donc vous voyez
à un moment
c'est ça,
c'est-à-dire
ils ont rejeté
la loi,
l'alliance
que Dieu
avait établie
avec eux.
Et cette alliance,
c'était qu'ils
devaient respecter
la loi,
mais Dieu
pointait aussi
le fait
qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas respecter
la loi.
Et voilà
pourquoi
il y avait
les sacrifices.
S'ils avaient
été capables
de respecter
la loi,
Christ n'aurait
pas eu besoin
de venir,
il n'aurait pas
eu besoin
de sacrifice.
Mais Dieu
leur commande
de respecter
la loi
pour qu'ils comprennent
le sens
des sacrifices
et qu'ils comprennent
le sens
du Messie
qui doit venir
et qu'ils comprennent
alors la mission
qui leur est confiée,
être une lumière
au milieu des nations
pour accueillir
le Messie,
le libérateur
des nations.
Mais ils ne l'ont
pas compris
et donc déjà
Dieu a jugé
le royaume du Nord
qui a été
détruit,
la population
a été déjà
déportée
par le royaume
de la Syrie.
Et ensuite,
et vous voyez,
les commandements
de Dieu,
ces commandements
étaient des choses
comme nous allons lire,
nous lisons
les dix commandements,
le symbolisme
il est même
déjà là,
on parle
de dix commandements,
on ne parle pas
de trente commandements,
on parle de dix commandements.
Dieu parle
de choses simples
mais ce sont
des choses
qui devaient
d'abord déjà
découler
d'une compréhension
de l'amour
envers Dieu.
Si nous aimons
Dieu,
alors tout ce que
j'ai cité tout à l'heure,
si j'aime Dieu,
je ne commettrai pas
d'adultère
dans mon couple.
Si j'aime Dieu,
un moment,
je ne ferai pas
de mal,
un mal conscient
à mon prochain
parce que je sais
que Dieu
n'approuve pas cela.
Si j'aime Dieu,
si l'homme
aimait Dieu,
la plupart des mots
que nous voyons
de l'homme
envers l'homme
ne seraient pas là.
C'est l'absence
d'amour vers Dieu
qui conduit
l'homme
à pouvoir
faire cela.
Et Jérémie
qui était
dans la même
bataille
qu'Ézéchiel
de leur faire
comprendre
que le jugement
était en train
d'arriver
sur Jérusalem
parce qu'ils avaient
rejeté la loi
et l'alliance.
Jérémie leur dit
un moment,
ainsi par l'éternel,
prenez garde
à vos âmes,
ne portez point
de fardeau
le jour du sabbat
et n'en introduisez
point par les portes
de Jérusalem.
Ne sortez de vos maisons
aucun fardeau
le jour du sabbat
et ne faites
aucun ouvrage
mais sanctifiez
le jour du sabbat
comme je l'ai
ordonné à vos pères.
Ils n'ont pas écouté,
ils n'ont pas prêté
l'oreille,
ils ont rédit
leur coup
pour ne point
écouter
et ne point
recevoir
instruction.
Notre frère
Nathanael
a mis
cette en face
tout à l'heure.
C'est quelque chose
de bête
mais c'est quelque chose
d'important.
À un moment,
la Bible,
dans Genèse,
il nous a parlé
de Dieu
qui crée le monde
pendant six jours
et qui se repose
au septième.
Et c'était une ordonnance
que Dieu donna à Israël.
C'était quelque chose
pour leur bien.
Et vous voyez,
à un moment,
ça va être une des causes
du jugement,
c'est parce qu'Israël
n'a pas respecté
le fait de mettre
le jour à part
où Dieu avait dit
vous ne ferez
aucun ouvrage
lors de ce jour,
vous le consacrerez à moi
à cause du fait
qu'Israël
n'est pas honoré
ce jour,
Dieu va les juger.
C'était,
c'est une leçon
pour nous aussi,
pour nous aussi
de comprendre
un moment.
Aujourd'hui,
nous sommes toujours
dans ce principe aussi
d'être toujours sur,
on va dire,
de ployer
sur le poids
des responsabilités,
de beaucoup de choses.
J'étais revenu là-dessus
sur des messages précédents
où à un moment,
on ne va pas réussir
à mettre ce temps
à part pour Dieu
parce qu'on va considérer
qu'on a très peu
de temps à lui donner.
On va considérer
un moment
qu'on était tellement occupé
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
d'ouvrir la Bible.
On va considérer
qu'on était tellement occupé
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
de prier.
On va considérer
qu'on était tellement occupé
qu'on n'a pas eu le temps
de demander des nouvelles
pour savoir
comment on va
tel frais
à telle soeur
dans la semaine
parce que nous,
on a un temps
qui est chargé,
qui est précieux.
Ce sont toutes ces choses
qui ont conduit
à ce que Israël
soit jugé.
La conséquence
pour nous,
encore là,
un autre point
dans l'enseignement
que cela nous donne,
c'est de faire attention
à préserver nos cœurs,
à garder nos cœurs,
d'avoir des cœurs mauvais,
des cœurs incrédules.
Le problème d'Israël
à un moment,
c'est qu'ils ont eu
un cœur incrédule.
Ils ont été confrontés
à l'alliance de Dieu.
Ils ont été dépités
parce qu'ils n'arrivaient pas
à accomplir la loi
par leurs propres efforts.
Alors,
ils ont décidé
de rejeter Dieu.
Et c'est extraordinaire
de voir aujourd'hui
des personnes
qui vont dire à un moment
qu'ils ont du mal
à comprendre
que Dieu
puisse leur demander
de juste croire en lui
et de ne pas venir
avec le fruit
de leurs efforts.
À cause du péché,
nous sommes conditionnés
à penser à un moment
que pour avoir
la grâce de Dieu,
il faut que nous la produisons
par nos propres efforts.
Mais Dieu montre
à Israël à un moment
que rien de ce que Israël
ne pouvait faire
ne pouvait trouver
satisfaction,
faveur à ses yeux.
Et voilà pourquoi
il leur demandait
de continuer
à faire des sacrifices.
Et cela a irrité Israël.
Israël a rejeté l'éternel
parce que pour eux,
le fait qu'ils ne puissent pas,
que Dieu n'accepte pas
le fruit de leurs efforts
était quelque chose
d'impensable.
Gardons-nous de nous détourner
de Dieu
à cause de ces choses.
Exhortons-nous
à ne pas nous laisser endurcir
par la séduction du péché.
Exhortons-nous
à ne pas nous laisser séduire
par la séduction du salut
par nos propres œuvres.
Souvenons-nous
que nous sommes devenus
participants de Christ.
Et non,
dursissons pas nos cœurs.
Israël a eu
près de
huit siècles
et même plus
pour
réaliser
ce que Dieu
était en train de faire.
D'ailleurs,
à une échelle de temps,
vous allez remarquer que
si on trouve Dieu injuste
dans ses jugements,
imaginons ce que représente
huit siècles de patience.
huit siècles de patience,
ce sont des générations
et des générations
où Dieu
a donné l'occasion
à Israël
de pouvoir rester
dans le droit chemin
de ce qu'il demandait.
Et vous voyez,
à un moment,
lorsque Dieu va
les déporter,
l'une des premières choses
qu'il va mettre en avant,
il va dire,
à un moment,
la terre va enfin respirer.
Cette terre
où vous n'avez pas honoré
le sabbat,
où vous n'avez pas pris
le soin d'honorer
mes commandements,
cette terre va enfin respirer.
parce que vous n'avez pas su
à un moment
obéir à ma loi.
Israël a servi Dieu,
mais Israël n'a pas pu aimer Dieu.
Nous pouvons avoir
ce désir
d'aimer Dieu,
mais nous allons
rester à un stade
où nous sommes en train
de le servir.
Nous allons rester à un stade
et voilà pourquoi
beaucoup de personnes
vont à un moment
se décourager
parce que quand nous sommes
dans ce stade
de pouvoir servir Dieu
sans pouvoir apprécier
l'amour de Dieu,
nous allons finir
par nous retirer.
Nous allons finir
par réaliser un moment
que nous sommes en train
de faire des choses
par nos propres efforts
et non par la grâce de Dieu.
Nous allons voir un moment
que ce que nous sommes
en train de vivre,
c'est une crainte
qui ne vient pas de Dieu.
C'est une crainte
qui est inspirée
par la crainte
du châtiment,
par l'espoir
d'une bénédiction
de Dieu.
J'ai vu des personnes
être terrorisées
parce qu'à un moment
elles n'avaient pas lu,
par exemple,
elles se sont levées
le matin,
elles n'ont pas pu lire
la Bible
et elles devaient
prendre les transports,
tout ça,
et elles étaient terrorisées
parce que si jamais
il y a un accident
sur la route,
c'est parce qu'elles
n'ont pas lu la Bible.
Mais ça,
c'est une très mauvaise
compréhension
de la grâce de Dieu.
Voilà pourquoi Dieu
demandait à Israël
de faire des sacrifices
parce que Dieu savait
à un moment qu'Israël,
il allait leur arriver
à un moment que oui,
ils ne vont pas être fidèles
parce que Dieu
demande de la loi.
Mais un jour,
il y a Dieu
au travers de son Fils
qui va accomplir
parfaitement la loi
pour eux.
Mais en attendant
que le Fils puisse
accomplir parfaitement
la loi,
il fallait que ces sacrifices
puissent retarder
la colère de Dieu.
Mais Israël n'a pas compris
l'importance
de ces sacrifices
et Israël a rejeté
la loi et les commandements.
Mais notre exhortation,
voilà ce que doit produire
la vraie crainte de Dieu
dans nos cœurs.
Vous pouvez relire
1 Jean 4
pour revoir un peu
ces aspects.
Mais la parole de Dieu
nous rappelle
que la vraie crainte de Dieu
produit en nous
une espérance
qui nous amène
à nous purifier
comme notre Dieu
qui est pur.
La vraie crainte de Dieu
produit un amour
qui nous amène
à aimer Dieu.
Et pourquoi
nous allons aimer Dieu?
La Bible nous le précise.
Nous n'allons pas aimer Dieu
parce que nous avons
fait des efforts
pour aimer Dieu.
Nous allons aimer Dieu
parce qu'il nous a aimés
le premier.
Le salut ne vient pas
de nos oeuvres.
Le salut vient de Dieu.
Et ça, c'est Jean
qui le dit à un moment.
Il va dire à un moment
nous aimons Dieu
parce qu'il nous a aimés
en premier.
Et alors nous avons
la vraie crainte de Dieu.
Mais si nous décidons
à un moment
que c'est nous
qui aimons Dieu
et qu'il est alors
venu en réaction
à notre amour,
nous sommes en train
d'être dans les oeuvres.
Mais la compréhension
à un moment
c'est que Dieu
nous a aimés le premier.
Son amour a été manifesté
dans nos cœurs.
Alors nous pouvons
répondre à cet amour
en respectant
le commandement
de Deutéronome 6
verset 5.
La vraie crainte de Dieu
va amener les chrétiens
à s'aimer les uns
les autres.
Va amener les chrétiens
à aimer leurs prochains
même quand cela va
contre la logique
de ce monde.
la logique de ce monde
à un moment
c'est que ceux
qui t'ont fait du mal
tu le leur rendes.
La logique de ce monde
à un moment
c'est que ceux
qui t'ont fait du mal
tu t'assures même
de les oublier
de ne rien leur faire
de positif.
Mais la logique
de la vraie crainte
de Dieu
c'est que quand nous
aimons les autres
même ceux qui nous ont
manifesté de la méchanceté
même en allant
jusqu'au meurtre
nous allons manifester
notre pardon.
La vraie crainte
de Dieu
produit un amour
parfait.
C'est un amour
qui n'est pas basé
sur la crainte
du châtiment
c'est un amour
qui rassure nos cœurs
face au jugement.
Si
notre salut
est basé
sur les œuvres
parfaites
que nous devons
accomplir
nous n'accomplirons
jamais ces œuvres
parfaites
elles ne seront
jamais suffisantes
pour notre salut.
Mais lorsque nous
nous repousons
sur le fait
qu'il y a un homme
qui a accompli
parfaitement
la loi
pour que nous
ayons le repos
céleste de Dieu
alors la vraie
crainte de Dieu
rassure nos cœurs
face au jugement.
Ce n'est pas une crainte
du jugement
c'est une crainte
respectueuse
de celui
qui nous a sauvés.
Celui qui aime Dieu
aime aussi son frère.
Et là
je peux vous laisser
à la conclusion
d'une nation
qui décide
de retirer Dieu.
nous avons vu
les conséquences
en France
depuis la séparation
de l'Église
et de l'État
on a décidé
d'enlever
le catéchisme
dans les écoles
on a décidé
d'enlever
un peu cet aspect
de morale
et de décider
à un moment
que la morale
devait être définie
par chacun
et nous sommes
en train
de voir
les conséquences
de ça
nous sommes
en train
de voir
les rébellions
nous sommes
en train
de voir
la violence
d'une jeunesse
qui ne fait
qu'augmenter
des choses
que nous n'aurions
pas vues
même quand
dans leur imperfection
on pouvait voir
la parole
qui était annoncée
même dans des écoles
catholiques
avec le catéchisme
et toutes ces choses
quand nous retirons
Dieu
nous ne pouvons pas
espérer
voir l'homme
se comporter
d'une meilleure façon
vis-à-vis de l'homme
le troisième point
pourquoi Dieu
donc le premier point
c'était
de comprendre
pourquoi Israël
était un sujet
d'effroi
et de honte
le deuxième point
c'était
qu'est-ce que nous
pouvons tirer
de ce que Dieu
a enseigné
au travers de cela
et le troisième point
c'est pourquoi
Dieu apporte
pourquoi Dieu apporte
sa signature personnelle
la signature personnelle
comme je vous l'ai parlé
quand nous lisons
les versets 13 à 17
c'est
c'est moi
l'éternel
qui parle
entre les versets
13 à 17
nous retrouvons
trois fois
cette expression
c'est un rappel
et donc je parle
d'un genre
de signature
qui prouve
que Dieu
est en train
d'orchestrer
ce que les israélites
sont en train
de vivre
plusieurs avaient douté
plusieurs
donc depuis un moment
les prophètes
ne faisaient que se relayer
il y avait plusieurs prophètes
qui avaient déjà annoncé
la destruction de Jérusalem
il y avait eu
Esaïe
il y avait Jérémie
il y avait maintenant
Ézéchiel
et il y avait même
d'autres prophètes
et malgré tout
ce que ces prophètes
étaient en train de dire
le peuple
était en train
de rejeter ce message
le peuple était en train
de considérer cela
comme un mensonge
donc plusieurs avaient douté
ils avaient rejeté
les prophètes
jusqu'à en tuer
mais même confrontés
au jugement
ils étaient en train
de rejeter
l'intervention de Dieu
et voilà pourquoi
Dieu est en train
d'insister
avec cette expression
lorsque Ézéchiel
va parler au peuple
il y aura cette expression
qui revient
c'est moi l'éternel
qui parle
il y aura
ces expressions
de colère
de fureur
qui sont en train
de montrer
que ces jugements
venaient de Dieu
à cause de l'idolâtrie
à cause du péché
d'idolâtrie
et c'est ce que nous avons lu
dans les versets
16 à 17
on va les relire
quand je lancerai sur eux
les flèches pernicieuses
de la famine
qui donnent la mort
et que j'enverrai
pour vous détruire
alors je crois que c'est
je vais lire
parce que
tu seras un sujet
d'opprobre
et de honte
un exemple
et un objet d'effroi
pour les nations
qui t'entourent
quand j'exécuterai
contre toi
mes jugements
avec colère
avec fureur
et par des châtiments
rigoureux
c'est moi l'éternel
qui parle
quand je lancerai sur eux
les flèches pernicieuses
de la famine
qui donnent la mort
et que j'enverrai
pour vous détruire
car j'ajouterai la famine
à vos maux
et je briserai pour vous
le bâton du pain
j'enverrai contre vous
la famine
et les bêtes féroces
qui te priveront
d'enfants
la peste
et le sang
passera au milieu
de toi
je ferai venir
l'épée sur toi
c'est moi l'éternel
qui parle
nous allons retrouver
beaucoup de similitudes
de ce texte
si nous allons
lire
je vais lire rapidement
vous avez les références
vous pourrez
revoir après
Lévitique 26
au verset 1
il va dire
vous ne ferez point
d'idole
vous ne vous élèverez
ni image
taillée
ni statue
et vous ne placerez
dans votre pays
aucune pierre
ornée de figure
pour vous prosterner
devant elle
car je suis l'éternel
votre Dieu
ça c'était les termes
de l'alliance
donc Israël n'a pas
obéi à ce terme
de l'alliance
Israël s'est fait
des idoles
de pierres
taillées
et ils sont donc
allés contre le sens
de l'alliance
au verset 2
il dit
vous observerez
mes sabbats
et vous révérez
mon sanctuaire
je suis l'éternel
Dieu insiste
sur l'importance
d'honorer le sabbat
Israël n'avait pas
honoré le sabbat
Dieu insiste
sur le fait
d'honorer
ce jour
qu'il a mis à part
où Israël
ne devait faire
aucun travail
il devait être
en train d'honorer Dieu
verset 14 à 15
mais
si vous ne m'écoutez pas
donc Dieu est en train
d'établir l'alliance
de bénédiction
d'établir les bénédictions
et malédictions
de l'alliance
il va dire
au verset 14 à 15
mais si vous ne m'écoutez pas
point
et ne mettez point
en pratique
tous ces commandements
si vous méprisez mes lois
et si votre âme
a en horreur
mes ordonnances
en sorte que vous ne
pratiquiez point
tous mes commandements
et que vous
rompiez mon alliance
donc déjà là
Dieu est en train
de prononcer la malédiction
il est en train de dire
si
vous pratiquez
ce péché
d'idolâtrie
si vous ne respectez pas
mes sabbats
et il y avait d'autres commandements
aussi
d'autres avertissements
voici ce qui arriverait
et là je ne prends
que les aspects
qui concernent
ce que nous avons lu
dans Ézéchiel
chapitre 5
des versets 16 à 17
Dieu parle
au verset 29
du cannibalisme
et ça nous l'avons lu
dans Ézéchiel
il dit
verset 33
verset 36
lorsque je vous briserai
le bâton du pain
dix femmes cuiront
votre pain
dans un seul four
et rapporteront
votre pain au poids
vous mangerez
et vous ne serez
point rassasiés
là
ce que Dieu
met en avant
voilà
huit siècles avant
voilà les jugements
que Dieu
est en train de citer
à cause du péché
d'idolâtrie
d'Israël
et ces jugements
se sont accomplis
de façon littérale
huit siècles après
il est en train
d'annoncer
au travers d'Ézéchiel
au travers de Jérémie
que ces jugements
vont s'accomplir
parce que Israël
n'a pas respecté
l'alliance
et vous voyez
dans la bonté de Dieu
il ne s'est jamais agi
du fait que
Dieu savait
qu'Israël
ne pouvait pas
respecter l'alliance
le problème de Dieu
c'était qu'ils respectent
ils comprennent
l'importance de la loi
c'est que
en attendant
dans leur incapacité
à respecter cette alliance
et nous voyons
par exemple
des hommes comme David
qui ont compris cela
dans ce respect
et de respecter
ils savaient
qu'ils ne pouvaient
pas respecter l'alliance
alors ils savaient
à un moment
que les sacrifices
qu'ils faisaient
même si ces sacrifices
n'hôtent pas le péché
ces sacrifices
retardent la colère
de Dieu
en attendant
que l'homme parfait
puisse accomplir
parfaitement la loi
même au moment
dans cette génération
pécheresse
ils ont choisi
de rejeter cela
de rejeter la loi
ils ont choisi
de rejeter les sacrifices
qui retardaient
la colère de Dieu
alors Dieu dit
parce que vous n'avez
pas fait cela
mes jugements
vont tomber
sur Israël
quelle est la conclusion
pour nous
la conclusion
et donc là
c'est la signature
personnelle de Dieu
c'est à dire
la signature personnelle
c'est le fait
qu'il avait annoncé
quelque chose
plusieurs siècles avant
et qu'il est en train
de répéter cette chose
et il dit à un moment
c'est moi l'éternel
qui parle
il met cette signature
ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui arrive comme ça
qui est sorti
d'une imagination
non
c'est quelque chose
qui avait été annoncé
bien avant
et même les jugements précis
Dieu s'apprête donc
et donc sur cette conclusion
pour nous aujourd'hui
en conclusion
de chapitre 5
Dieu s'apprête
à accomplir ses jugements
contre Jérusalem
il y a certains
qui doutent encore
parce que nous verrons
plus tard que
la chute de Jérusalem
va arriver
pendant qu'Ézéchiel
est encore en train
de prophétiser
certains doutent
que cela arrive
ils ont même l'assurance
que
alors
je ne vais pas vous faire
un cours de géopolitique
c'est Babylone
qui avait assiégé Israël
et beaucoup
espéraient que l'Égypte
puisse chasser Babylone
et comme il y avait
des liens forts
entre l'Égypte
et Israël
alors l'Égypte
allait libérer Israël
donc beaucoup
avaient cet espoir
que l'Égypte
allait libérer
mais ce qui s'est passé
c'est que Dieu
a permis que
Nébuchadnezzar
écrase l'Égypte
donc à un moment
le siège de Jérusalem
s'est arrêté
et quand le siège
ils étaient convaincus
qu'Ézéchiel
et Jérémie
étaient les menteurs
et quand le siège
s'est arrêté
Nébuchadnezzar
est allé vaincre
le pharaon d'Égypte
et il est revenu
faire le siège
de Jérusalem
et cette fois-ci
il a détruit Jérusalem
et donc Ézéchiel
Jérémie
n'avait pas tort
donc certains doutaient
que cela arriverait
mais par l'intermédiaire
des prophètes
et dans notre cas
d'Ézéchiel
Dieu confirme
qu'il le fera bien
que ce peuple
qui s'était engagé
à respecter
l'alliance de Dieu
et qui ne l'avait pas fait
allait déclencher
à cause de leur désobéissance
l'exécution
des jugements promis
et nous le voyons
comme nous l'avons lu
dans Deutéronome
dans la critique
mais même dans cette
manifestation de fureur
et c'est très important
pour nous
je vous l'ai dit
notre Dieu
n'est pas un Dieu injuste
même dans cette
manifestation de fureur
nous voyons comment
Dieu ne manque pas
de miséricorde
et d'amour
il n'est pas dans
une colère injuste
même si Israël
n'avait pas tenu
sa promesse
lui il promettait
malgré tout
de les restaurer
même si Israël
avait échoué
Dieu est en train
de dire
tout ce qui est en train
de vous arriver
et pour votre instruction
et pour votre correction
en tant que nation
qui devait accueillir
le Messie
et vous allez voir
ce qui va se passer
c'est que
quand Dieu
va les frapper
ils vont être déportés
ils vont revenir
au bout
de 70 ans
les premiers exilés
vont revenir
et à la suite de ça
des nations
vont encore
les asservir
il va y avoir
plusieurs nations
l'empire perse
va les asservir
d'autres empires
après
Alexandre
les remplaçants
d'Alexandre
l'empire romain
beaucoup
de nations
vont les asservir
mais aucune autre nation
ne va les chasser
comme ça avait été le cas
et là maintenant
cette nation
va être prête
pour accueillir le Messie
4 siècles plus tard
à peu près
le Seigneur Jésus Christ
va venir
donc même si Israël
n'avait pas tenu
sa promesse
Dieu
promettait
de tenir
la sienne
Dieu
avait juste
mis en avant
pour Israël
l'impossibilité
de respecter
l'alliance
il voulait leur rappeler
l'importance
de comprendre
qu'ils avaient besoin
du sauveur
qui devait venir
et voilà
un passage
avec beaucoup
d'espoir
c'est un passage
avec beaucoup
d'espoir
toujours dans
l'hévitique 26
après que nous ayons lu
ces choses difficiles
voilà ce qu'il dit
dans le verset 40 à 45
et qui s'est accompli
aussi littéralement
un moment
Dieu va susciter
des hommes
comme Daniel
qui vont comprendre
un moment
qu'Israël avait péché
et ils vont prier
pour le pardon
d'Israël
ils vont prier
pour que Dieu
pardonne les péchés
d'Israël
pour que Dieu
restaure Israël
et Dieu dit
à la suite de ça
ils confesseront
leurs iniquités
et les iniquités
de leur père
les transgressions
qu'ils ont commises
envers moi
et la résistance
qu'ils m'ont opposé
péché à cause desquels
moi aussi
je leur résisterai
et je les mènerai
dans le pays
de leurs ennemis
et alors leur cœur
incirconcie
s'humiliera
leur cœur
incirconcie
le problème
c'est qu'ils avaient
besoin
de cette opération
du Saint-Esprit
qu'ils n'avaient pas eue
pour pouvoir aimer Dieu
de toutes leurs forces
mais là Dieu dit
à un moment
leur cœur
incirconcie
s'humiliera
et ils payeront
la dette
de leurs iniquités
je me souviendrai
de mon alliance
avec Jacob
je me souviendrai
de mon alliance
avec Isaac
et de mon alliance
avec Abraham
et je me souviendrai
du pays
le pays sera abandonné
par eux
et il jouira
de ses sabbats
pendant qu'il restera
dévasté loin d'eux
et ils payeront
la dette
de leurs iniquités
parce qu'ils ont méprisé
mes ordonnances
et que leur âme
a eu mes lois
en horreur
mais lorsqu'ils seront
dans le pays
de leurs ennemis
je ne les rejetterai
pour ton point
et je ne les aurai
point en horreur
jusqu'à les exterminer
jusqu'à rompre
mon alliance
avec eux
car je suis
l'éternel
leur Dieu
je me souviendrai
en leur faveur
de l'ancienne alliance
par laquelle
je les ai fait sortir
du pays d'Egypte
aux yeux des nations
pour être leur Dieu
je suis l'éternel
gloire à Dieu
Dieu
leur avait déjà signalé
et ce que nous devons
retenir là dessus
quand nous voyons
quand même
ce message d'espoir
que Dieu donne
Dieu leur avait déjà
signalé
qu'il les châtirait
parce qu'il les aimait
là il est en train
de dire
un moment
vous n'allez pas
respecter l'alliance
vous allez la rejeter
mais j'inclinerai
vos cœurs
vers le pardon
j'inclinerai vos cœurs
vers la repentance
et je vous restaurerai
et donc Dieu va dire
un moment
qu'il les châtie
parce qu'il les aime
il va les frapper
de sa verge
parce qu'il les aime
pour quelque chose
de plus glorieux
et la chose la plus glorieuse
c'était de les restaurer
dans le but
qu'il leur avait donné
le but initial
c'était d'accueillir
le Christ
nous aussi
nous devons prendre conscience
que chaque fois que Dieu
nous corrige
c'est pour nous rendre
conformes au Fils
le Dieu éternel
qui a fait de nous
un peuple acquis
au Père
nous ne devons pas
nous décourager
quand Dieu est en train
de nous reprendre
à cause de nos fautes
nous ne devons pas
nous décourager
parce que comme Israël
lorsque nous péchons
nous allons vivre
les conséquences
de notre péché
mais nous devons nous souvenir
que Dieu ne nous punit
jamais à la hauteur
du châtiment
que nous méritons
nous avons un Dieu
qui est infiniment juste
qui est infiniment bon
nous pouvons vivre
les conséquences
de notre péché ici bas
et c'est mieux
que nous les vivions
ici bas
car Dieu châtisse
ceux qui l'aiment
Dieu nous corrige
afin que nous puissions
participer à sa sainteté
que nous ne soyons pas
incrédules
comme on l'a pu l'être
de nombreux Israélites
qui pourtant connaissaient
la vérité
et la vérité
que nous devons connaître
c'est que c'est Dieu
qui est l'auteur
de notre salut
c'est Dieu
qui est l'auteur
de notre persévérance
dans la foi
c'est Dieu
qui est l'auteur
de notre compréhension
et de notre salut
comme Israël
le châtiment de Dieu
peut paraître
source de tristesse
et non de joie
lorsque nous vivons
les conséquences
de notre péché
mais il va produire
plus tard
pour chacun de ces enfants
qui est passé par là
un fruit paisible
de justice
qui trouve sa source
dans l'œuvre du Christ
et